A delegation of Houthi rebels has arrived
in Sweden for talks with the Yemeni government
aimed at ending a four-year war that has led
to the worst humanitarian catastrophe in recent
times.
But distrust between the warring parties is
high.
Passports and tickets in hand, for a journey
many hope will bring peace.
A delegation of Houthi rebels waiting to board
their flight to Sweden.
The UN's special envoy Martin Griffiths has
been instrumental in setting up the talks
with the Yemeni government.
Such is the distrust between the two sides,
the rebels wouldn't get on the plane without
him.
Our basic guarantee is the presence of the
UN envoy with us on the same flight.
This is the only guarantee we have for going
there."
The evacuation of 50 wounded Houthi fighters
from the warzone on has also helped built
confidence in the talks -- with the conflict
locked in stalemate.
The Houthis -- backed by Iran -- control the
northwest of the country, including the capital
Sanaa, which they took in 2015.
The government -- backed by Saudi Arabia and
the UAE -- has set up base in Aden, in the
south.
Four years of conflict have left thousands
dead and created what's been described as
the worst humanitarian crisis in recent history.
With Yemen's economy crippled, more than 14
million people -- many of them children -- are
facing starvation.
It is a country at war, as I've heard many
say, this is a country on the brink of catastrophe.
This is not a country on the break of catastrophe,
this is a country that is in a catastrophe.
A catastrophe that's unfolded in full view
of the whole world, but one many say has been
ignored.
The hope is the talks will result in a truce,
allowing food and aid to reach those who need
it most.